according to axios jd vance's win in
ohio it's upset all the right people
saying the republican establishment
privately regards vance with the same
disgust many felt toward donald trump
when he entered the white house on jan
20 2017
but vance of course overcame millions of
dollars of negative ads from globalist
groups like the club for growth to win
it
so could this be the beginning of an
american first takeover of the us senate
and who could be next well blake masters
is hoping he is he's running for the u.s
senate in the state of arizona blake
great to see you tonight thanks for
being here um
how can you kind of
capture this i mean if it's possible the
ohio momentum
against more wars you know for economic
growth all the issues that the america
first agenda cares about and move that
through arizona and a crowded primary
absolutely laura we're doing it every
single day you know we're seeing a
seismic shift america first it's here to
stay president trump launched this
movement in 2016 and man he upset the
apple cart he upended the political
establishment i think he literally saved
the country by winning in 2016. you know
when he did it by running on and then
delivering this bold agenda it's secure
the border right it's stop the senseless
wars abroad let's be smart and tough but
we got to stop that he delivered this
economy that worked it worked for
american workers and families and you
know laura he doesn't get enough credit
for this part people forget about it
president trump championed traditional
conservative causes it's because of him
more than anybody else that we right now
have the most pro-child pro-family
pro-life supreme court that this nation
has ever seen it's it's incredible and
uh the the energy has shifted now
speaking of uh
of the pro-life issue mark kelly the
incumbent democrat senator
has just come out in favor of codifying
roe vs wade i mean as we said we got the
country falling apart on all these
different levels
and the democrats are rushing in to
essentially say we need more abortions
that's the holy grail for them in
arizona how does that issue play
very candidly
i think it's a pro-life state and i
think this is a pro-life country you
know mark kelly he doesn't care about
the open border he doesn't care about
inflation that's why he's a rubber stamp
vote for the joe biden agenda what he
does care about apparently
is unlimited partial birth abortion he
can't articulate any single restriction
he's four he's all for planned
parenthood going in at seven months in
utero to sever spinal cords and
dismember babies i'm sorry to be so
graphic but like we have to talk at this
level that's what it is i think it's
ghastly he's out of step with arizona
and um you know i'm running on a bold
agenda this this president trump 2016
agenda it was great on the life issue
it's great on every issue okay this is
the playbook that me and other rising
leaders are using um we're not all the
same we sound different you know we have
different styles you can't copy
president trump he's one of a kind but
the common thread here again on this
life issue and everything else is we're
mad as hell and we're not going to take
it anymore what's happening to our
country it's unacceptable what the left
is doing unacceptable and we're going to
take this country back
are you concerned that kind of the
majority what would be new majority
leader number two number three number
four they're all
i mean
to quote larry kudlow they're all nice
guys right there friends nice guy but
they're all part of the old gop
establishment for the most part
they're very pro-war in ukraine i mean
they for spending a lot of money there
billions and billions of dollars
uh and the trade stuff they're not
they're definitely not with trump on the
tariffs uh in china they want to lift a
whole bunch of tariffs which would be
disastrous for our economy and our
manufacturing base um so are are you
concerned that that's that is a wall
that that america first senators would
not themselves be able to cross or get
across
well maybe you can't cross the wall
we're going to punch right through that
wall though we need a change right the
establishment politics isn't working uh
the same old republican talking points
the same old republicans in office it
doesn't work anymore you know what the
left is doing is is is crazy you've got
open borders you've got skyrocketing
inflation skyrocketing crime or they
literally want to teach your
eight-year-old to be transgender okay
and then if you complain about it
they'll call you a terrorist attack it
seems like the old guard
the old guard blake i'm sorry to
interrupt but the old guard doesn't like
to talk about those issues i i feel like
oftentimes they feel those issues are
icky they'd much rather talk about how
we have to have you know more trade with
you know asia or we have to spend more
money to send our values which our kids
are taught our racist values overseas so
they're comfortable there and maybe on
tax issues they don't like the other
issues so you
do believe those issues are important
then we'll let you go
absolutely no i want to be the party of
low taxes i like low taxes absolutely
but the republican party cannot just be
the party of low taxes right if that's
all we are then we'll lose but no what
about esg scores right we need to ban
those from fortune 500 right we need to
de-locify this country we need to stop
chinese-style social credit systems
before it happens here right you need
new energy in the u.s senate that's what
jd represents uh that's what i represent
we need a vibe shift you get us in there
we will materially change how the u.s
senate works i like that yeah
i help you go to blakemasters.com
and blake i like the young vibe coming
from a lot of you guys i think we need
to mix it up it's time for the next
generation to come in blake great to see
you thank you so much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else